one of the things we all struggle with  is despair and you can tell when your  faith is low your despair is rising  that's a rule and you know despair is  not you know a lot of people treat  despair like it's a backache chronic  back problem or something sciatica  but unfortunately despair is not like  sciatica  it's like melanoma if you didn't get  anything else what I'm talking about  today than that it's that's important to  get despair is aggressive like melanoma  and if if you are noticing despair in  your life you have got to attend to your  faith a thing ASAP because if you don't  attend to your faith ASAP there's a  certain finite period of time that you  have before that despair will  metastasize and take you down and it has  a lot of different forms of taking you  down you could probably write each of  you write it write your own book about  how despair affects you